It's time for Drew's news
(crowd cheers)
Hi everybody,
Drew's news where we crack open that ice cold cans
of refreshing good news.
And with me at the desk is a man who really knows
how to relish that first sip it's Rossy Ross Matthews.
(Ross laughs)
Hi everybody. Hi, hi Drew.
(crowd cheers)
All right should we get right into it?
Right into it.
Right in, first up, we've got the latest
in snack science today.
It's food news.
Nom, nom, nom. Mm-hm
Ross if you could walk down any aisle with any snack food,
who would the lucky snack be?
God, this is very serious question.
So I took it very seriously.
My gateway food of all foods is pizza. Pizza is,
(crowd cheers)
like the two I broke up with and when I see them out,
I'm like, oh, don't look at me.
(man laughs)
Oh, that's funny.
Cause I'm always like best friends with all my exes.
And that's exactly how I feel about mac and cheese.
I only have heart eyes for this,
and you know, sometimes I want to take it easy on the cheesy
but how do I just say no?
(Ross laughs)
Well, insider reports that science says you can resist
by using your old sniffer ru.
Researchers at the university of Florida say
that if you smell your favorite snack for two minutes,
the craving can disappear.
And you're basically tricking your brain
into thinking that you ate it.
Ross we're the guinea pigs today
and you've got a slice of za right in front of you.
Hello, hello lover.
I know, right?
(crowd cheers)
All right. Let's give it a good whiff.
Okay.
Oh, it does smell like pizza. Hi.
(crowd laughs)
I just want a motorboat it.
(Ross laughs)
oh, gosh, I don't know.
Okay. Well, we're just going to keep on sniffing
until the end of the news
and then we'll really ask ourselves.
But does anyone think this could work?
Raise your hands if you think it's like plausible.
Yeah-
Not that many hands.
I'm kind of with those of you
with your hands down.
Now, I want pizza more than I have in months.
Like now I'm like-
(crowd claps)
As they say, bite down.
Just a little bite. I blame you.
Why you got me smelling pizza up here?
I don't know, but you know Ross, it is your story.
Oh, wait, alright-
(crowd cheers)
That is worth it!
I know, you know what,
you know what it tastes like?
Pizza.
(Ross and Drew laugh)
All right you keep chewing Drew.
And in the meantime, I'll talk about this.
Yahoo life reports Olivia Wilde and Harry Styles,
who I call Wilde Styles-
Ooohh.
Thank you very much,
were spotted in LA wearing matching outfits,
they call it twinning.
And apparently it's the new thing.
Tons of celebs have been known to go matchy-matchy.
Look at these ones,
Brad Pitt twinning through his relationship history.
There's member this with Gwyneth, with Jen, with Angie-
Wow. He really does.
Mm-hmm.
He really twins.
I think it's cute.
I don't think you should like identically match,
like think when in doubt think like Destiny's Child,
remember, how they were all through half a dairy
and coordinated, but they weren't identical.
Do that. That's cute.
I, I will say Wellington and I, my fiance,
we coordinate, we don't match, which I think is less tacky.
Well, I'm not to cut it on Wellington,
but you and I coordinate, which I really love.
(crowd cheers)
Yeah, well, we do it every day.
There's Wellington and I,
we are in matching velour jumpsuits
that I literally bought at Forever 21.
(Ross laughs)
Ah, I love that.
Isn't that cute?
You know, you and Wellington
are planning your big wedding day as we speak.
So I gotta get your take on this next story
because this one really does it for me, all right?
The New York Post reports that Doug and Deidre,
a couple from Chicago recently went viral,
when they issued an invoice to all the guests
who flaked on their wedding.
(Ross laughs)
Look at that. I'm not kidding. This is real.
They sent an official bill
and they're charging $120 per person
to everyone who said they did,
but then they didn't.
Uh-huh.
And they didn't show up in Negril, Jamaica
for the big day.
(crowd claps)
The couple says they asked for confirmation four times
and none of the no shows bothered
to write, texts or call that they couldn't make it.
Ross, what are your thoughts?
Are you going to put in voices into people's boxes?
Who do this to you?
Okay. I am planning a wedding
and I don't know if you heard, but they're not cheap,
but if there were a no-show at my wedding,
I'd like to think that I would send this,
but I don't think I, I would.
I think I would just silently resent you
and then slowly cut you out of my life.
(crowd laughs)
I think that's the natural thing to do,
but I kind of get it, they should've let them know.
They should've let them know.
And maybe they had like the best reason in the entire world.
I would love to get to the bottom of this.
Me too, which is why Doug and Deidre.
We want to talk that's right. We want to reach out.
(Ross laughs)
And we find if a guest or two would come on and talk to us
about why they were a no-show. And did they have a reason?
I'm not kidding.
Yes, yes, yes.
Right?
(crowd cheers)
And I want to invite all of you and everyone at home,
what's your take on the flake? Are you like a holdout?
Do you think this is a good idea? Do you disagree?
We want to hear about this.
I think this is a movement in the making
and it's a little dangerous, but it's also a little dope.
So Ross, your story.
I, I want them all to come on, plead their case.
Can we get judges robes and then decide? Yes?
(crowd cheers)
Who's in the right, who's in the wrong.
I'll pull an RVG.
Okay.
(Ross laughs)
All right boss, your story. Oh God.
Stay tuned everyone, okay give me this
and then I'll tell you the story.
Thank you.
(crowd laughs)
Okay, taking over here,
I'm going to put it next to my pizza. We can-
Oh.
Goodbye.
Okay.
Finally, we've got a really touching story from Australia.
I saw this, I showed Drew
and we had to tell you all about it.
People reports that a farmer named Ben Jackson,
rallied his flock of sheep to pay tribute
to a special family member.
His aunt, Deb, recently passed away
after a long battle with cancer
and Ben couldn't make it to her funeral because of COVID
and travel restrictions.
So instead, he honored his incredibly giving aunt
with a flock shaped heart on his land in New South Wales.
Look, he made the-
How do you teach? What? How do you do that?
But it was so beautiful and touching.
What a beautiful gesture, you know,
I think that was just lovely.
Ever since,
(crowd cheers)
you know, this is always the way I love
to kind of end the news
because Ross brought this to my attention
and I haven't been able
to get the visual out of my head ever since.
And it's something that I can now go to in moments,
I can travel to in my mind as a destination of peace,
tranquility and beauty.
And Rossy always, you're the one who taught me this.
Thank you.
Thank you Drew.
(upbeat music)